[Applause]
[Music]
Merritt Morris isn't just in the middle
she's on top I definitely have
solidified my place in this genre and
while the country star may be killing it
today her success in music didn't happen
overnight when the 28 year old dropped
by watch what happens live she opened up
about all the knows she faced early on
in her career how crazy is it that
you're rejected by both American Idol
and The Voice but both shows had
contestants covering your song are you
you were rejected from both of those
shows oh yeah that's not even it I was
rejected from like America's Got Talent
there were a ton that I didn't make it
to thank God yeah sorry right someone
else would on your sheet but Morris
didn't take the rejections to heart and
she is grateful for the way her career
has panned out in fact contestants on
the same shows that rejected the country
star are singing her hits today
[Music]
now people cover my songs for their
auditions when those shows so it's like
not only is it really nice to have my
song on a national television show get
to collect the check and have some sweet
revenge since her breakthrough in 2016
we're so blessed to get to do this right
away
Morris has earned six Grammy nominations
I was in bed and my mom woke me up with
a phone call saying that I had been
nominated four times and I I was
instantly awake I didn't really need any
caffeine that day to wake up it was
incredible I mean I'm still sort of
living in that and it's crazy that there
tomorrow night so I'm yeah I'm a happy
girl and she just released her second
studio album girl
we gotten used to this yet all the
pageantry and the lights on you because
you I mean the success that you've had
over the past year has been really
something to see
thank you I don't think anyone really
gets used to it I think you adapt to it
and it is fun I think I have more fun
like that now than I did in the
beginning because it's nice to like get
dressed up
[Music]